dos cierres de campaña en la mira del
mundo en Turquía los aspirantes a la
presidencia concluyeron sus eventos
públicos el actual presidente y
candidato a la reelección
se dio un último baño de masas allí el
mandatario criticó las presuntas
intenciones de su contrincante de
penalizar a Rusia por la invasión a
Ucrania
que dice el Señor que mal dice que
pueden imponer sanciones a Rusia Qué
tipo de pensamiento es ese señor quemal
Qué tipo de entendimiento es este erdoan
también acusó a que Mike de recibir
órdenes de Washington
vas a hacer esto siguiendo las
instrucciones que recibiste desde
Estados Unidos con las instrucciones que
recibiste de biden por su parte kilisa
lorou acompañado por un grupo de
simpatizantes visitó mausoleo que guarda
los restos del fundador de la Turquía
moderna mustafakke malata
una entrevista realizada el viernes el
político respondió a los constantes
ataques de erdogan
él siempre está usando trucos sucios
nunca he visto un hombre mentir tanto
como él lo hace en toda mi vida
distorsiona los hechos y calumnia a la
gente pero haga lo que haga la gente me
elegirá horas antes de la apertura de
las urnas los kurdos hicieron escuchar
su voz en medio de la difícil situación
económica que vive el país La minoría
kurda representa un 20% de la población
y sus votos podrían ser decisivos